اولاد الموضوع ينضم الينا الان في
الاستوديو هنا اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري
والاستراتيجيه اهلا بك معنا بدايه ودائما
حول هذا الانسحاب الروسي في خيرسون تحديدا
كنت قد قلت في احدى النشرات على الجزيره
بانه كان متوقع لماذا
بسبب موازين القوى
الفاعله على الارض الذي اعترفي الصراع كان
الحديث عن 40 الف مقاتل روسي ومن ثم
التقرير في اخر فتره كان 25000 روسيا تم
الاجلاء 70,000 80,000 15,000 طرق الامداد
مقطوعه الجسور شبه معطله القوات لا يصلها
امداد وبالتالي قدره القتاليه بدات همم
تضعف اضافه الى ذلك كان الخوف من تدمير
السد كخوفك وبالتالي كان هناك مجموعه من
العوامل وكنا نرجح دائما ان الانسحاب
سيحصل لان اليد العليا به للقوات الاخراني
بما تملك من ولكن رغم ذلك لم نكن ان نتوقع
ان يتم الانسحاب او اصدار امن الانسحاب
الامر الانسحاب دون خوض معركه حاسمه تضعف
القوات المهاجمه لكن كانت المفاجاه انه
القائد الميداني عرض ايجاز وزير الدفاع
وفق وتم صدور الامر
المفاجاه في التوقيت وعدم خوض معركه حاسمه
لاضعاف القوات المهاجم هذا القوات تقدر ما
بين 100 الى 120,000 هذه سيكون لها دور ما
بعد الانسحاب سواء فيما وراء النهر او
توظيفها في مناطق اخرى
والقوات الروسيه خلف النهر ولكن همم تحاول
ان تقوم بمناره ما في يسار نهر
تحديدا والقوات الاوكرانيه قد تواجه
المساحات المفتوحه الان امام الطيران
الروسي كيف ستكون
حتى هل تم اخلاء كافه القوات لا تتوقع ذلك
لماذا
لو كان هناك الاخلاق خلال 24 ساعه هذا
يسمى بتحت مصطلح معتمد في معاهد الجيوش
كلها بالانسحاب السريع وهو الاقرب الى
الانسحاب الفوضي وبالتالي هذه القوات قد
تفقد توازنها وتصبح لقمه سائغا للقوات
المهاجمه قسم منها يدمر قسم وبالتالي حتى
الانسحاب اذا كان القائد حريص على ان ينقل
قواته بكفاءه قتاليه عالي متزنه لابد ان
يتخذ اجراءات معينه اهم هذه الاجراءات
المعركه
الروسيه من الجهه الشماليه والغربيه
الشماليه هناك القوات الاوكرانيه وخلفها
دينيرو
من القوات الروسيه القوات التي ذهبت الى
ما وراء نهر النيبر هذه القوات تقوم ببناء
الخطه الدفاعيه والان هي تصبح مدافعه
والقوات الاوكرانيه مهاجمه وليس فقط مهاجم
مهاجمه عبر مانع مائي كبير يحتاج الى
اجراءات خاصه وعمليات عسكريه من نوع خاص
لكن السؤال المطروح هل القوات الروسيه
انسحبت اذا انسحبت خلال 24 ساعه فهناك امر
غير طبيعي معناته هذه القوات منذ اسابيع
تجري انسحاب دون معرفه ان يتم سحب 25000
خلال خمسه خلال 24 ساعه يعني ان القوات
الاوكرانيه لم تقود بدورها العملياتي كان
يجب ان تلحق اكبر ضرار فيها لان هذه
القوات اقرب الى الهزيمه من هذه الانسحاب
المتجه طيب يعني انت تحدثت عن اكثر من
سيناري وهل الان في هذه اللحظه يمكن ان
نحدد الميكانيكيات هذا الانسان
اتصور الانسحاب يجب ان يكون كالاتي والا
ستكون هناك كارثه تحلب القوات الروسيه هذه
القوه واضحه بطريقه يقال لها طريقه
التخفيف ومن ثم عمليات مصطلحات عسكريه قد
تامر مشاهد التبادل والتعاقب وما شابه ذلك
وجود حرس مؤخره يديم الاشتباك مع القوات
المهاجمه حتى لا تتمكن اختراقات وعمليات
تطويق واسر قسم كبير من الجنود اذا لم
يتخذ هذا الاجراء القائد الميداني لا
افاجئ غدا ان تخرج القياده الوكانيه
وتتحدث عن اسر المئات والالاف من الجنود
الروسي سنتافي
انه روسيا لا تقدم هدايا فهو ينظر الى هذا
الانسحاب انه قد يكون يحمل خدعه ماء او
تحفظ من انه قد يكون احتماليه عوده الروس
بشكل
همم من ضمن الاشكال ان يترك الجيوب مقاومه
مختفيه تقاته الحرب عصابات الخداع الاخر
ان تكون تجهيز المنطقه بما يسمى عمليات
الشراك الخداعي والتي ستب- تسبب الكثير من
الخسائر يتم تلغيم كل شيء وتفقيقه كل شيء
وبالتالي تصبح هذه المنطقه يعني
وقد تفضي الى خسائر كبيره في القوات التي
تدخلها لها لاحقا
اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
ولسترجي